now question six in the textbook it
actually scaffolds it a lot for you
there's like a part a part be a patsy
I think but I actually just want you to
think with me if the question for this
was just graph if that's all you were
told there was no scaffolding okay on a
normal graph what kind of information is
important to put on there just shout
that something's up
say yeah okay so I'm gonna look for
turning points are gonna be pretty
useful what else underneath intercepts
points and inflection are probably going
to be handy if we had something which
had asymptotes then they would be
relevant but for this graph you're going
to find in a second there are none okay
that's good we're going to do calculus
to find out all of these things one
quick thing before we launch into it
does this look familiar this particular
form do you remember this from a topic
last year what kind of topic gave us
equations that look just like that
Jamilla
this is auxilary angle do you remember
so if you if you remember what we saw
before when you add two wave functions
like this you get you get another wave
function that's like like bigger and
it's also been like shifted across left
and right that's what the auxiliary
angle is about I only play that out just
so you have a rough idea of what to
expect when we get there okay
so let's get going I am actually going
to suggest we start out working in two
sets because you don't need calculus for
that do you okay so to begin let's do
x-intercepts x-intercepts occur when
when y equals zero
can you go ahead and work out what the
x-intercepts are let's go from nought to
2pi that's a that's a good is that
that's probably the main right no it's a
2 pi I'll give you a minute to have a go
at that yourself
oops
[Applause]
go ahead and work out your y-intercepts
while you're at it yep
oh you're right yeah I'll show you right
thank you
do I have some solutions for the
x-intercepts plasma solutions how many
solutions you expecting I'm expecting in
this domain hmm
so standard domain not to 2 pi and so if
you wanted you could use this guy right
if you want it's not the only way but it
works fine 10 is negative so which
quadrants am I in 2nd and 4th these guys
so now that I've got the quadrants out
of the way I can not worry about the
sign the sign just tells me other
quadrants so if I think about one on
route 3 if you went to your calculator
because you couldn't remember your exact
values you could go shift n of one on
route 3 now I will point out you're
probably thinking rightly I should be in
radians mode because I'm going to be
calculating derivatives and all that
kind of thing however if you're working
out exact values cuz radians or in terms
of pi you're going to get read decimals
at the end which you might not recognize
so if you're trying to find out what
this is it's totally ok to be in degrees
just remember to come back has someone
got the answers for me what's the base
angle that's the base in 30 degrees so
that's PI on 6 so PI on 6 in the second
quadrant is going to be PI takeaway PI
on 6 yes so that's going to be five
pounds IG's in the fourth quadrant Pilon
six is going to become 2 pi takeaway
pile and six yeah so that's going to be
11 PI and six
all right so I'll just keep them in the
back of my mind for when I put these
onto the graph there are my x-intercepts
and I've got two of them y-intercepts
they're easy to find
substituting x equals zero by now we
should know what cozier is it should be
cos of 0 cos of 0 is 1 plus root 3 times
sine of 0 sine of 0 is 0 so there is my
y intercept ok now I do not bless you I
do not have enough space on my board to
actually have my my graph going as well
but if I were you I would start now to
draw your set of axes draw it from
naught to 2pi and I'm going to start to
put this information on I'm going to
assemble it as I go I'm gonna do a
really awful rough version over here
that I'm going to replace just so I
don't have to remember everything so if
I've got my Malta to PI let's put two pi
somewhere over here so you play I want
to have some rough markers so I know
where to place these values for instance
so I'm gonna chuck PI right there in the
middle so now I've got yep
yeah that's a good question I'm gonna
write this the way it is because this
equation here X can only take one value
or the other but the way I interpret
that is for the graph it has both of
those as solutions okay so I'm going to
put five pile-on six there just before
pi and eleven Pilon six there just
before two pi and then I've got one I'm
gonna put that somewhere like that so
I've got some points of intersection
great one of those other things you told
me I needed to find you listed them for
me right I'm gonna need turning points
and points of inflection now I'm gonna
put you to work for a minute how do we
find turning points we we differentiate
and use the first derivative okay how do
we find points of inflection we're gonna
have to differentiate again use the
second derivative to look for where the
concavity is zero okay so off you go
find your first derivative my just
second review I'll give you a bit of a
head start and as you find features
start to add them on to your graph okay
off you go and we found some stationary
points because we differentiating got
this there's our first derivative okay
now normally I would go through and in
fact the question asks you to find the
nature of these things however because
I've just asked you to graph you're
going to get these coordinates PI on 3
comma 2 is gonna be about here and 4 pi
and 3 comma D negative 2 is gonna be
about there now I think you can tell me
which one of those is a max and which
one is a min because of where they are
ok now if the question asked you go
ahead find the nature but they're there
they are
I'm you'll find your points of
inflection and then you'll get this
shape that's just going to stop there
which verifies what you would have seen
in ordinary angle last year ok so thanks
everyone